Першого грудня Міжнародний день боротьби з ВІЛ/СНІДом.
Ми спілкуємося з головою координаційної ради
міжнародного фонду "100% життя" Дмитром Шерембеєм.
Доброго дня, пане Дмитре.
Доброго!
Отже, за даними ООН,за останні 5 років кількість виявлених захворювань
у світі зменшилася на 20%, але в Україні
ступінь поширеності  захворювання серед дорослого населення
серед країн Східної Європи та Центральної Азії залишається найвищим.
Скажіть, що не так з Україною?
Насправді, так. Це результат пізнього втручання.
Епідемія розвивалася, складно було її контролювати.
В неї не інвестували ресурси.
В неї інвестували ресурси лише міжнародні донори.
І тут настає момент, коли Україна перетнула ту межу,
коли кількість інфікованих людей стала дуже великою.
І, звичайно ж, це потребує більше зусиль, більше грошей.
На жаль, Україна проґавила той момент, коли епідемія
могла б бути контрольованою від самого початку.
Чи багато людей вмираютьвідВІЛ та СНІД?
Сьогодні статистика нерадісна.
Вона насправді ніколи не велася в Україні, або демонструвала дуже невеликий відсоток.
7 тисяч людей, які вмирають,
це не те число… Ці дані нам не доступні насправді.
Чому? Тому що велика кількість людей, які вмирають з ВІЛ, їм не пишуть в картку,
що вони померли внаслідок захворювання.
Тому що діагноз їм не був поставлений.
Вони потрапляють в лікарні на термінальній стадії, коли організм зруйнований.
Але, при цьому технологія лікування доступна.
Тож, вони могли і не вмирати.
Вони померли, тому що в них немає імунітету, щоб протидіяти будь-якій нежиті,
чи-то якійсь серйозній хворобі.
І вони йдуть з життя абсолютно безпідставно.
Чи вдалося вашій організації домогтися від уряду переведення
усіх препаратів для лікування ВІЛ/СНІД на міжнароднізакупівлі?
Так, на сьогодні абсолютно весь портфель антиретровірусної терапії
закуповується через міжнародні організації.
Загальний обсяг економії може сягати до 30 мільйонів на рік.
Так заощаджуються бюджетні ресурси.
Цей інструмент продемонстрував кілька речей.
Перше - це те, що корупцію дуже просто подолати,
якщо запросити в закупівлі гравців, які просто некорумповані.
Міжнародні організації з 2-х мільярдів гривень зекономили Україні
800 мільйонів. 800 мільйонів гривень!!! Це фантастичні гроші,
які просто знайдені в площині правильного управління ресурсами.
Ви давно боретесь за те, щоб проблемі ВІЛ та СНІД в Україні
приділяли більше уваги, але і держава має запитання до вас
Якщо ми згадаємо про всі ті кримінальні справи, які
проти вас відкривалися, проти вашої організації. Що з ними?
Чи має держава досі питання до вас?
До вашої нібито співпраці з ФСБ,
з так званими ЛНР/ДНР.
Тема  перерозподілу коштів Глобального фонду на підтримку терористичних організацій?
Так, картина виглядає так,
що всі ці кримінальні справи же закриті.
Всі суди ми виграли. Ми - організація,
яка 15 років поспіль проходить аудит
двох найбільших аудиторських компаній -
PricewaterhouseCoopers і The Voit.
Система нашого аудиту, система безпеки ресурсів,
вона набагато вища, ніж системи перевірки КРУ.
Вся ця історія… Вона ж не з’явилася лише зараз.
Вона була при Януковичі, була при всіх.
Ми - організація, яка вкрай радикально виступає в антикорупційному сенсі.
І, звичайно, це викликає негативну реакцію в державній системі,
де втрачають гроші.
Якщо міжнародні закупівлі ліків зекономили 800 мільйонів гривень,
це означає, що корупціонери
не отримали 800 мільйонів гривень.
Корупціонери - це хто?
Ну, це ті, хто курирували всю систему охорони здоров’я до цього.
Це ті чиновники, які відповідають.
Це відділ СБУ, який курирував усі закупівлі МОЗ. Чому?
Тому що всі організації, які боролися за те, щоб терапія,
зокрема, для лікування ВІЛ/СНІД, закуповувалася через міжнародні організації,
це благодійний фонд "Пацієнти України", Центр протидії корупції,
фонд "100% життя "… Проти них усіх порушено кримінальні справи. Одразу.
Тому що корупціонери втратили мільярд,
і їм треба було хоч щось вигадати. Що ми співпрацюємо з НЛО,
з потойбічним світом і так далі… І всі ці залякування…
Вони, звичайно, для когось мають жахливий вигляд.
Але, ви знаєте, при Януковичі залякували складніше,
пряміше, жорстокіше, і погрози виглядали більш жахливо, ніж зараз.
Звичайно, це погана характеристика для державної системи.
важливо те, що це продемонструвало, що громадянський сектор
більш стійкий, ніж вони очікували.
Тому що мивчиняли наші дії, щоб вижити нам,
вижити тим людям, яких ми представляємо.
І ми взагалі-то не плануємо зупинятися.
Чи є якась нова статистика з приводу того,
скільки людей мають позитивний статус?
В середньому, ми все одно знаходимось на межі 20 тисяч нових випадків на рік.
Офіційно. Але реформа системи охорони здоров’я змінить тепер
історію епідемії в Україні. Чому? Тому що кожний лікар сімейної медицини
отримує можливість тестувати людей і призначати терапію.
Тобто рівень довіри до лікаря сімейної медицини набагато вищий,
ніж до всієї системи лікування СНІДу в Україні.
І, таким чином, ми розуміємо, що реформа медицини
напряму вплине на загальну ситуацію з епідемію ВІЛ/СНІД,
гепатиту С ітуберкульозу в Україні.
Ви хочете сказати, що саме реформа в медицині змінила ситуацію?
Можете навести конкретні приклади?
Держава збільшила фінансування на закупівлю антиретровірусної терапії
з 200 до 900 мільйонів гривень.
Це дуже прямий вплив на лікування хворих на ВІЛ/СНІД.
Тому що 90 тисяч людей - зареєстрованих -
тепер забезпечені терапією, і в нас, по суті, в туберкульозі,
СНІДі - 100% забезпеченість ліками.
Це дуже важливо. І з кожним роком ця забезпеченість збільшуватиметься.
Друге, Україна знаходиться на етапі виконання зобов’язань,
які вона дала ООН  і всім іншим донорам,
що вона сама почне витрачати свої кошти на зупинення епідемії в Україні.
І в2019році вже закладені в бюджет ресурси.
Всі ці характеристики - це не якісь номінальні обіцянки.
Це конкретно задокументовані речі,
які ми можемо чітко спостерігати вже в лікарнях і в житті пацієнтів.
Ситуація в регіонах. Ви впевнені в тому, що в Одесі,
Миколаєві, Запоріжжі так само добре, як і в Києві?
Тобто люди з позитивним статусом можуть одразу
прийти йотримати безкоштовну терапію без жодних проблем?
Всі, хто дивиться це інтерв’ю, слухає його, повинні знати:
в Україні безкоштовна терапія! За неї не треба платити, її купила держава.
Ні 50, ні 20, ні 10 доларів.
Звичайно, місто Київ відрізняється від інших міст своєю прогресивністю.
Тут терапію можна отримати в аптеці.
Тут все мобільніше. Велика концентрація послуг.
Скажімо так, все розвивається більш динамічно.
Але існують міста маленькі, приміром, Херсон,
або інші якісь маленькі міста, в яких все не так динамічно розвивається,
в яких реформу не так швидко реалізовують.
В яких перешкодою для людини може стати, приміром, те, що вона наркозалежна,
їй не видають антиретровірусну терапію. Це поодинокі випадки, але вони є.
Людину можуть поставити в такі умови,
коли вона вимушена якось мотивувати лікаря,
або поставити її на облік за для отримання терапії,
або їй  просто не видають терапію. Ми дуже раді, що система змінюється.
Але залишки старої є і це відбиває будь-яке бажання лікуватися.
Ви багато разів казали, що ціни на лікивукраїнських аптеках
мінімум вдвічі вищі, ніж вони мають бути.
Якваша боротьба з фармацевтичним лобі?
В Україні аптека - це, по суті, монопольний ринок.
По суті, він належить трьом власникам або 4-ом групам.
Вони диктують свої будь-які умови кожному, хто заходить туди.
В будь-якому випадку ця фарммонополія має бути зруйнована.
В нас немає наразі прямої відповіді: як ми будемо впливати.
Але і будемо боротися за те,щоб хоча б реклама зникла,
яка мотивує людей придбати ліки, які не треба купувати.
Це раз. А друге, щоб монополія була зруйнована з точки зору аптечного обігу.
Як це зробити,я ще не можу сказати.
В нас є своя закрита пропозиція для держави.
Ми сподіваємося, що нас почують.
Ви символічна фігура в Україні. Ви боретеся
проти поширення ВІЛ та СНІД.
Чи не хотіли б ви все кинути і поїхати геть?
Я колись лежав в палаті, важив40 кгі вмирав через те,
що в мене було три смертельних захворювання. ВІЛ, туберкульоз та гепатит С.
Від мого організму, по суті, нічого не лишилося.
І лікар, який зайшов до мене, сказав, щомені залишилося жити 2 місяці,
щоб я там не придумував. Ви знаєте, цю історію я, як приклад,
часто згадую в усіх інтерв’ю. Я сказав, що не вам вирішувати, скільки мені жити.
От пройшло 18 років.
І ми допомагаємоі тій лікарні, і  тому місту, і людям в Україні.
Ви знаєте, в моєму житті ще був один випадок,
який визначив мою участь в цьому русі. Не лише мій діагноз.
Це коли я побачив,що новонародженого малюка
не обслуговуваливлікарні, який кричав та плакав, кричав та плакав.
Маля лежало на мокрому - в сечі -  матраці, в холоді,
до нього не підходили медсестри. Тому що це був малюк,
від якоговідмовилася ВІЛ-позитивна мати.
Я зрозумів, що навіть і в пологовому будинку відмовляються від хворих на ВІЛ та СНІД.
І це була пружина, яка спрацювала миттєво.
Ні! Поки ця дитина не буде закутана,
нагодована, ми не маємо права зупинятися.
Кому з хворих на ВІЛ та СНІД
ви взагалі не можете сьогодні допомогти?
По-перше, тим, кого вже з нами немає.
А по-друге, це люди, які ще не знають про свій діагноз.
1 грудня - Всесвітній день боротьби зі СНІДом.
І ми розуміємо, що більше100 тисячлюдей
не знають про свій діагноз. Це дорослі люди,
вони одягаються по-дорослому, ходять на дорослі роботи.
Це директори, якісь викладачі, вони різні.
В Україні більше 52% інфікуються статевим шляхом.
Це не наркозалежні. Це не люди, які зайняті
в комерційній статевій галузі.Це прості гетеросексуальні стосунки,
в яких люди не здають тест на ВІЛ.
Так ось, на перше грудня ми придумали такий символ.
Ось, це ж виглядає безглуздо, якщо я її візьму.
Ось уявіть собі, що йде дорослий такий дядя з соскою вулицею.
Смішно? По-дурному. Ось так безглуздо
виглядає страх знати правду про стан свого здоров’я.
Ми хочемо, аби люди повикидали соски
і просто здали тест на ВІЛ.
Це одна хвилина часу.
Дякую дуже.
Дякую, що порушуєте такі складні теми в ефірі.